welcome everyone uh I'm gonna be talking
about SAR this is a storage format for
storing chunk compressed and dimensional
arrays
uh my name is sanket Verma and I take
care of community and OSS at Tsar I have
been working there as a community
manager for almost a year
I I also have been involved with pi data
since last six years so I chair Delhi
which is like my regional chapter and
I've also shared the previous two
particular local conferences this year
I'm not checking the content this year I
just only took care of the program
committee and in the previous and before
working to Zara I worked with forensics
startups and organizations in data
science roles and when I'm not working I
like to play violin and on the right
hand side of your screen you can see
there's a pixelated version of my in my
photo which this basically represents I
like to do pixel art and if you like
this talk you can go and follow me on
Twitter I post about a lot of cool
things over there
so yeah uh jumping into the topic today
uh so what I'm gonna show you like what
is our uh how's our works
and this is going to be some like
visualization using some pretty neat uh
diagrams and stuff and then I'm gonna
jump into some code Snippets
after that uh like why and when to use
the language there are so many data
science lab does there are so many data
formats to use and why specifically use
SAR and then what is specification and
then implementations and what what
community looks like
uh by the way I also have the stream
open on my other monitor so if you like
to if you have any questions you can uh
just post it over the YouTube chat I'm
having a look over there
so yeah uh Inception of Tsar so how did
basically is all started so Alice the
Tsar was created by Aleister miles and
he he used to work he works with uh
genome sequencing data of Malaysia
muscular mosquitoes which contains
malaria viruses and it started back in
2015 and he needed basically a data
format to handle large data sets when I
say large I mean in gigabytes and
terabytes and petabytes and that's when
the that's that's where the uses are
basically originated and it has a
privately growing user base and Industry
and it's industry ready like we see I
mean we always track the downloads in
our Pi Pi and stats and there are the
numbers have been always increasing and
currently we have 21 codefs uh which is
for the Tsar python implementation and
it is currently fiscally sponsored by
non-focus and also funded by Caesar die
which is Chan Zuckerberg initiative
which is the non-profit arm of Facebook
under the USS EOS stands for essential
open source software
uh there are some links in the bottom of
your screen which is for Twitter GitHub
and the website
uh so before I jump into the technical
details and how Czar basically works so
this is what I mean I I just wanted to
show like how beautiful this all is so
this so on the screen that you see there
are two types of data from different
domains on the left hand side you can
see oceanography data and on the right
head you see microscopy data so I mean
these data are basically stored in the
format and you can just do a simple uh
simple command and a simple simple one
line code and you can get this data into
our into your notebooks or in your
browser
so yeah I mean that's the beauty of Czar
uh let's
I mean yeah not not X not uh spoiler
alert so yeah
so before before we go into Tsar like
let's just look have a look at what area
tensor is uh so a container of item is
basically known as tensor when you want
to contain items or data into into a
structured manner you basically use
arrays and tensor over there so you can
you can see there's a representation of
like one dimensional two dimensional and
multi-dimensional there is on the screen
and we you have we use different bits
for the data like 8-bit 16 bit 32 bits
and 64 bits and these are different
different different uh sizes of data
that we use to represent our storage
uh the number of dimensions and items in
container are described by shape so
basically what's your shape of data
looks like is basically how the
dimensions would look like so if you
have like a 1D data in just a single row
it looks like one D if you have uh like
columns and rows then it looks like 2D
data and if you have column rows and
then another axis which is like 3D data
like in n-dimensional arrays and it it
will look like it will look like like
free 3D data
yeah so yeah yeah I mean what is that so
Zar is an open source source
specification format for storing chunk
compressed and n-dimensional arrays and
I I just want to break every every term
in this sentence so whenever so what
does mean by specification specification
is basically uh and Technical a
technical document which lays out rules
of how the array should be stored how it
should be jumped basically divided how
it should be compressed and how it
should be grouped into a store and so
Tsar is based on a technical document
and on the on the base of this technical
document we have implementations in
different languages so there are
fantastic developers all around the
globe who have basically used this
technical documentation and
created the libraries in Python Java
Julia Julia
JavaScript C C plus plus and I think the
uh R is also catching up and so Alistair
basically created the uh open source
specification and these are python
library and since it's since it's
beautiful use case other developers have
also pitched in and they started making
their own implementations
so yeah
um so yeah so let's just so let's dive
into like how's our works basically so
so imagine this is your data that you
want to store and you can I mean let's
just say this the size of this data is
probably I don't know maybe 100 MBS or
200 MBS or few GBS it's easy to store on
your laptop and you have because you
have this space and you have memory but
what if the data is like too bit too big
to fit in the memory it it's it's
impossible I just say you have one TV of
data you don't I mean I haven't seen any
laptop or any machine having one TB of
memory I mean you could have disk space
for like terabytes but yeah but not not
too big to fit in your memory so uh what
basically zaw does it it divide your
areas into chunks and you can see all
this uh beautiful representation is
basically divided into equal chunks and
compress those compress those individual
chunks using compressions compressors so
uh there's a there's a library known as
num codex which is which is also
supported by Zar and which is also under
these are developers GitHub organization
it supports a range of compressors so
the default compressor that we use for
compression is gloss like if you don't
mention like what compressor you're
going to use to compress our data the
blast the blast will be picked up but if
you specify what compressor you want to
use you can just do that using a string
compressor
and
when you compress those chunk and that
your data is basically divided into
equal chunks and compressed and and you
can retrieve the chunks only when needed
so let's just say you have a data worth
of I don't know maybe
a few g400 GBS and you want to work with
the only only initial like the first 100
chunks for the data or the first 20 tons
of the data so you can retrieve retrieve
only those chunks work with the data
read it write write some data out of it
and then store it back into the storage
so that's the beauty of Zao like you can
basically uh
store as as large as data as large as
your disk size and you can select the
data you want to work on which is like
which is sufficient for your memory and
then work on it write some data on it
and then store it back
uh yeah so but how does the uh
what does the organization or what does
the hierarchies hierarchy looks like so
Czar multiple arrays like if you have
multiple arrays which is basically
chunks can be organized in hierarchies
of groups so uh the uh the The Violet uh
blobs that you see there are basically
chunked chunk data which is in binary
format and the green green blocks that
you see these are basically metadatas
and which is in Json format so we have
used the uh Json format for storing
metadata because it's easily uh like
it's widely used and easily readable
across different libraries and different
systems
and yeah this so this is this basically
represents like how the chunking and the
compression Works basically so every
chunk is assigned a key a unique key and
it is being compressed uh using the
compression and
we basically use set item in Python so
basically a mutable we use mutable
mapping to basically uh assign the chunk
assign the chunker key and its value so
value is essentially the compressed data
which is in boundary blob and each blob
is given a unique key and they are
referenced by that key so uh you take
that contiguous chunks like big because
these chunks are like contagious and
pass it through any optional filters and
a compressor and that gives you a
sequence of white and that sequence of
by byte gets stored as a mapping from
the respective key so conceptually all
of the stores are store is just a key
value stored and where key are strings
and the uh see and the values are
sequence of bytes uh so any system which
can expose the key value system type
interface can use our store so that's
like really easy because uh there are a
lot of stores in SAR like which are
already built into that which uses this
key key value stored mutable mapping
and uh in Python implementation we use
mutable mapping interface to set and
retrieve Zar data which is like set item
to set the keys and data and get item to
get retrieve the data using a key using
the using the key and its respective
values
so
[Music]
um
cool uh
so yeah let's jump to some code uh
I have prepared a notebook
I hope my screen is visible
yeah it's uh clear enough
Okay cool so yeah uh uh basically
increase the font size a bit
okay sure uh for me to say clearly oh
there you go good cool yeah cool so uh
basically is our uh python API borrows
many Concepts from numpy so I just
wanted to dive a little bit little bit
of basics of numpy and how does it look
like so what we're gonna go what we are
gonna do here is create a numpy array
with the shape of 10 by 20 and using the
flow data type so you can see the array
is created and we want to see like uh
how how basically the uh
for the size of the array and watch what
how does memory the array uses it's 1600
bytes uh and we want to basically
getting a piece of data with slicing so
we're gonna use the last two uh last
last two uh positions to get the value
and it's it's zero zero because we
haven't fill anything to it and then
we're gonna use create a new array which
is B and assign uh the
the a the a array to the previous one
which you have created and you can see
the when we try to see the uh B uh which
is the first
I'm sorry the first the first array and
the the first position and the last
position you can see that it's being
filled so that's like pretty basics of
numpy like how the numpy array works and
how the slicing works and how the
assignment assignment in the numpy area
works uh so yeah let's let's move on to
our fundamentals and like uh what these
words are looks like like how how to
basically create arrays and work with
sort so Zar has three important
properties which is the shape uh the
data type and the attributes uh
so what I'm what I'm going to do here is
I'm using this is our create function
and I'm gonna use this the shape of the
area of by thousand by thousand like
thousand columns and thousand rows and
I'm gonna do I'm gonna divide the whole
chunk into my 10 by 10 blocks and I'm
gonna use the float data type here and
this is the this is the name of the like
uh store like this is stored into like
I'm gonna show into the Explorer like
how does it looks like so this is the
test dots are which is going to store so
let's go and run this command and we can
see that uh it's our code array is
created with thousand by thousand shape
a thousand thousand and it's uh
now data type is float so now we have
this function sar.info which is which
basically shows the info of the array
web we have just created so you can see
uh the shape is like thousand by
thousand chunk the order is C uh and the
compressor is blocked which has which I
initially mentioned that if you don't
pick I haven't picked any compressor yet
so you can see the compressor the
default compressor that have been picked
here is flask and uh the number of bytes
it shows a number of bytes stored and so
the important thing that we have to see
here is that the chunks initialize are
zero that I mean the reason that
initialized chunks are zero right now is
because we haven't written anything to
solve and as soon as we start writing
through the to the to your Czar the
chunks will get initialized as as you
start writing so let's just say if you
write the right data to only your first
100 chunks only the only those hundred
first hundred times would be initialized
so we're gonna see that in the next next
steps so we're gonna use fill value
because I mean that's the uh uh
if I want to use fill value to just
initialize with like 0 0 like all the
zero datas so no data has been returned
to Tsar yet uh but if it but if you try
to access the data we'll just get the
fill value so because we used Phil alley
which is uh which is like a default to
zero and this this has been set zero so
you can see the initial chunk which is
uh the first chunk which is z one zero
so uh now what I'm gonna try to do is
I'm going to
write the write one into the first 500
chunks of the data so when we do this
the data gets immediately written so
let's do this uh yeah
and if I'm gonna try to see this it's
gonna say zero zero because uh right now
uh it hasn't been returned into the last
chunk like the last one which was like
zero by zero so and if I do like zero
by zero you can see it's going to be one
and if I go by Z info you can see only
the initial 500 Chunks sorry 5000 chunks
are initialized
so uh your basically and I'm not sure if
I can
uh is my screen visible if I shift to
another
uh yeah you're we're viewing another
desktop right now
okay cool cool uh so you can see uh in
this is the test dots are which I which
just has been created and if I open it
uh you can see uh I mean I can go at the
bottom of this uh
uh so yeah it's gonna be only 5000
chunks which are initialized because
I've written only because I've written
only to the first 500 Chunks and if I go
back to my notebook and if I go here and
I'm gonna type
uh to this sorry
uh yeah
and I'm gonna do yeah let's do this and
if I'm gonna do Z info so you can see
all of the chunks are initialized so
your data was basically stored in the
disk but it was not but it was it it
gets only initialized when you start
writing to it
and if I go back here and you can see
like yeah I mean all the things are
initialized and they have something
written it I mean the data in it is in
it is binary but here you can see that
channels have been initialized
so yeah I mean so the so the so the so
the beautiful thing here is like uh the
data gets uh like you can you can read
and write data according to your that's
not like you have to load a big
monolithic file and you have to work on
that so that's the uh beauty of using
sort
uh and yeah I mean a little bit on the
uh attributes uh okay cool
uh so we can attach arbitrary metadata
to our array attributes which basically
is a very flexible thing and which is
very beautiful thing if you're working
with different applications because your
metadata contains information about data
and you can you can manipulate the
metadata according to your need so I'm
just gonna do uh like a unit meter per
second and standard name wind speed so
you can see the Z active Z actor Z
attributes which was
this metadata
you can see over here is being
is being changed it's been changed by Me
It's Been Changed by just using a simple
command and if I want to see like what
what's happening under the hood like how
your data is actually stored and so
there's a Tsar store function which lets
you look under the hood and the ability
to look under Czar store understand what
is what is there is a very neat design
so I'm gonna do this and yeah so you can
see uh
there is like certain errands or
attributes which is at the top which is
which contains immediate information and
then comes your data and you can also uh
just use the simple Json and try to see
like what does your Z array looks like
and it has all the information like for
your chunks the compressor compressor
information the radio type your fill
value filters your order how you wanna
access your data and what your shape and
whatever format is so what so what does
our format two means is like it's our
specification version 2.
and uh and if I open set attributes
which which I just changed and you can
see uh its standard name is wind speed
and unit is like meter per second
and there's one more thing uh
okay so we have time yeah so uh we uh
there's a there's a group like this is a
very uh another neat feature in Tsar
which is like creating SAR groups and
which is basically I mean in simple what
is the hierarchical organization of
different Aries and sort so I just
created a group in czar which is like uh
looks like looks something like this and
if I want to see so there are like two
folders like bar Foo and bar and in bar
we have uh different like path default
folder bars and then QX and under under
Cooks we have two data two data sets two
Zar data sets we have which have float
data types and in Data Drive and under X
and under y we have similar data types
with having float and data type and if
you want to see uh this uh so this is
just a small uh visual representation uh
interactive interactive representation
of what your group looks like so if I
can expand this and I can see you know
what's lying into my identity so you can
you can store multiple datas into
different hierarchies using Zar group
and I mean that's that's really neat if
you want to have like a tree structure
of data and you want to experiment with
different stuff and you want to copy one
data from one folder and go into go
above in you know hierarchy and store
data into that that that uh
that folder
uh and yeah and the last thing is that
we can so this is like a very neat thing
like uh so uh the string that you see
here is the uh link for uh zaw data
which is online and I can just use
Simple saw.open to open this
data I can print the values of
the unique values of uh Czar data using
this simple function so this basically
so shows that SAR is also compatible
with Cloud systems like Azure Cloud uh
Amazon AWS and Google Google cloud
system there's a lot of documentation
over in the Czar official documentation
which you can refer to
uh cool uh so I think I should get back
to my slides I do have a few slides to
uh complete
uh yeah so I think I just showed you
like what does the uh
initialization reading and writing of
looks like and how you can uh organize
arrays into hierarchies and what does
our store looks like and how can you
manipulate the metadators are and if you
want to learn more you can go to the
official documentation which is over
here
um so yeah I mean reasons like why what
why why won't we use R so arrays can be
read and written concurrently from
multiple threads and processes so this
is this is very interesting thing and uh
you can write uh two different uh
different chunks in multiple multiple
threads and processes it's easy to easy
to extend an append and it chunks arrays
along any Dimension you can chunk errors
along any tension and it's due to the
num codex Library it has extension
extensive support for compression and
it's easy to plug in compressor just by
changing the string value support local
and cloud storage system which is
basically essentially any key value
stored and simple and based on open
specification which allows it to be
hackable and uh just two just to focus
on the uh multiple uh concurrent writing
of threads uh if each so let's just say
uh think there's a very uh generic
problem of right right locks so if each
writer is writing to a different region
of an array and All rights are basically
aligned within the chunk boundaries then
locking is not required and but if
writer not allowed not aligned with
chunk boundaries then locking could
happen so uh this is like one of the uh
I would say
uh thing that need to be the thing that
needs to be considered when writing a
risk writing to Zar arrays concurrently
uh yeah yeah uh like when to use R so
just as I said before like when you have
absurdly large data sets and you don't
have enough memory to work with that and
when you want to share big data sets
across multiple points having key Value
Store really helps us so uh if you want
to like share your multiple data across
like multiple points you can use the key
value store to basically extract only
those things which are necessary and
then share them and if you're working in
the cloud and you want to read and write
read and do concurrent rights you can
erase and also be cool among your
friends so yeah uh and one yeah so I I
also have like this uh visualization oh
sorry illustration to show like how is
all is different from other file formats
so uh this was basically made by Henning
Fox uh we have we have other uh
illustrations by him in our repository
uh in in our GitHub repository so uh on
the left on the left hand side you can
see there's a format known as Tiff which
has like which is like 120 GBS of data
and it's like a big monolithic file
which has the which has binary data
spread across its file and if you want
to share that uh data that we need to
probably you need to basically pick up
that whole monolithic file of 120 GB and
just share it on the point but
instead like we have SAR where
everything is like chunked and
compressed and you can access data
across through any through any Dimension
and through any through any uh like you
can just if you have the key you can
access that data so it's not like that
you have to go through the whole data to
just get lost last byte of the
information and so you can use the key
key to just access the last bit and you
can just do that and I can show and I
just showed you the uh how does the uh
Czar store looks like in a file explorer
yeah so
okay so yeah so it it has a technical
space I mean I think I talked briefly
about what's our specification looks
like so it has a technical specification
uh
specification provides a technical
protocol for format for storing solar
arrays currently version 2 is in effect
and it basically tells us how
hierarchies are organized how arrays are
jumped and grouped and how metadata
should look like uh and we are uh
actually moving really fast with V3
which is the next version of the uh
specification and there are some big
changes over there and you can track the
progress over here itself one I would
share I would share the slides after the
talk so you can you can have access to
all of the links
uh yeah so another thing so another
another beautiful uh another feature
which makes our beautiful is the
interoperability
sorry so Tsar read and write to Zar
stores using you can read and write to
zaha store using task Etc and and data
so and other libraries which are under
pirate ecosystem so you can see I have
just uh I mean attached the screenshot
for how does the uh like how does x-ray
how you can how you can use Zar using
x-ray so uh you can use you can open
your store using X array with the simple
function x-ray dot opens are and you can
write using data set like x-ray to date
dot dataset tools are so basically x-ray
task and and data have built back and
have backends in backends of Czar built
on them and you can basically use R
without using zar and that's an
ambiguous statement but yeah that's how
it is and that's how like that's how
much the community loves are and they
have been using it and and we have also
examples for tasks like how like how you
can use uh Czar from this from task and
this is like load and writing like
loading there's our array and storing to
start array and uh just as mentioned we
have implementations in different
languages so python being the most used
one and then we have C plus plus and net
then Java C Julia JavaScript and server
mode and in and yeah the technical the
specification is uh open source and free
so if you want to uh start implementing
zarya just hit me up and we are more
than happy to help you
and uh yes our community uh so our
community is essentially the users the
developers the maintainers the
contributors and the and everyone who
uses are in any way and I mean there's
no formal process to join us just drop
over to our getter and say hi we hold uh
bi-weekly Community calls where you can
basically join us and if you have any
questions you can just drop his propos
and let us know if you find if you do
anything exciting with Zar feel free to
you know tag us on Twitter and let us
know on the guitar getter on GitHub we
are more than happy to uh
uh Echo it and uh yeah and we we are
also uh we also have this ZIP which is
the new governance process for Czar and
how does
how does new feature will Implement in
our spec I'm not gonna dive more into V3
because I'm running out of time but yeah
uh I think that's uh that's it for the
talk and these are some examples for
data sets which is like you can see on
the left hand side which is the 54
terabyte set of sea surface temperature
and on the left hand side you can see
one petabyte data of uh climate model
data so these are like really big data
sets and you can see they all use R to
store the data sets
and you are welcome at our community
meetings this is the link for our
community calls uh we just had a
community call yesterday we're gonna
have this meeting today which is about
Zips and also we are doing a Sprint
tomorrow so you are welcome to join and
maybe this would be our first open
source contribution and we have a lot of
good issues to work with you
so yeah uh see you all I hope I hope it
was informative if you have any
questions feel free to drop them into
the chat or Discord I'm going to be on
the Discord and yeah thank you